THE MOST VOLATILE REGION IN OUR
WORLD.
TODAY, BECAUSE AMERICA
NEGOTIATED FROM A POSITION OF
STRENGTH AND PRINCIPLE, WE HAVE
STOPPED THE SPREAD OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS IN THIS REGION.
BECAUSE OF THIS DEAL, THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY WILL BE
ABLE TO VERIFY THE ISLAMIC
REPUBLIC OF IRAN WILL NOT
DEVELOP A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
THIS DEAL MEETS EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THE BOTTOM LINES WE
ESTABLISHED WHEN WE ACHIEVED A
FRAMEWORK EARLIER THIS SPRING.
EVERY PATHWAY TO A NUCLEAR
WEAPON IS CUT OFF.
THE INSPECTION AND TRANSPARENCY
NECESSARY TO VERIFY THAT
OBJECTIVE WILL BE PUT IN PLACE.
BECAUSE OF THIS DEAL, IRAN WILL
NOT PRODUCE THE HIGHLY ENRICHED
URANIUM AND PLUTONIUM THAT GIVE
THE NECESSARY TO BUILD A BOMB.
THE MACHINES NECESSARY TO
PRODUCE HIGHLY ENRICHED URANIUM
FOR A BOMB AND STORE THEM UNDER
CONSTANT INTERNATIONAL
SUPERVISION.
IRAN WILL NOT USE ITS ADVANCED
CENTRIFUGES FOR ENRICHED URANIUM
FOR THE NEXT DECADE.
THEY WILL GET RID OF 98% OF
THEIR EURANIUM.
THEY HAVE A STOCKPILE THAT COULD
PRODUCE UP TO TEN NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
BECAUSE OF THIS DEAL, IT WILL BE
REDUCED TO A FRACTION OF WHAT IS
REQUIRED FOR A SINGLE WEAPON.
THIS STOCKPILE LIMITATION WILL
LAST FOR 15 YEARS.
BECAUSE OF THIS DEAL, IRAN WILL
MODIFY THE CORE OF ITS REACTOR
IN IRAQ SO IT WILL NOT PRODUCE
WEAPONS GRADE PLUTONIUM AND IT
HAS AGREED TO SHIFT THE SPENT
FUEL FROM THE REACTOR OUT OF THE
COUNTRY FOR THE LIFETIME OF THE
REACTOR FOR AT LEAST THE NEXT 15
YEARS, IRAN WILL NOT BUILD ANY
NEW HEAVY WATER REACTORS.
BECAUSE OF THIS DEAL, WE WILL,
FOR THE FIRST TIME, BE IN A
POSITION TO VERIFY ALL OF THESE
COMMITMENTS.
THAT MEANS THIS DEAL IS NOT
BUILT ON TRUST.
IT IS BUILT ON VERIFICATION.
INSPECTORS WILL HAVE 24/7 ACCESS
TO IRAN'S KEY NUCLEAR
FACILITIES.
IRAN WILL HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR
ENTIRE NUCLEAR SUPPLY CHAIN, THE
URANIUM MINES AND MILLS,
CONVERSION FACILITY AND THE
STORAGE FACILITIES.
THIS ENSURES THAT IRAN WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO DIVERT MATERIALS FROM
KNOWN FACILITIES TO COVERT ONES.
SOME OF THESE TRANSPARENCY
MEASURES WILL BE IN PLACE FOR 25
YEARS.
BECAUSE OF THIS DEAL, INSPECTORS
WILL BE ABLE TO ACCESS ANY
SUSPICIOUS LOCATION, PUT SIMPLY,
THE ORGANIZATION RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE INSPECTIONS, THE IAEA WILL
HAVE ACCESS WHERE NECESSARY,
WHEN NECESSARY.
THAT ARRANGEMENT IS PERMANENT.
AND THE IAEA HAS ALSO REACHED AN
AGREEMENT WITH IRAN TO GET
ACCESS IT NEEDS TO COMPLETE ITS
INVESTIGATION INTO THE POSSIBLE
MILITARY DIMENSIONS OF IRAN'S
PAST NUCLEAR RESEARCH.
FINALLY, IRAN IS PROHIBITED FROM
PURSUING NUCLEAR WEAPON UNDER
THE NONPROLIFERATION TREATY,
WHICH PROVIDED THE BASIS FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY EFFORT
TO PROVIDE PRESSURE ON IRAN.
AS THEY TAKE STEPS TO IMPLEMENT
THE DEAL, THEY WILL RECEIVE
RELIEF OF THE SANCTIONS PUT IN
PLACE BECAUSE OF THE NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
BOTH THE AMERICAN SANCTIONS AND
THOSE IMPOSED BY THE SECURITY
COUNSEL.
THEY WILL BE PHASED IN.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT
DECADE, IRAN MUST ABIDE BY THE
DEAL BEFORE ADDITIONAL SANCTIONS
ARE LIFTED, INCLUDING FIVE YEARS
FOR RESTRICTIONS RELATED TO ARMS
AND EIGHT YEARS FOR RESTRICTIONS
RELATED TO BALLISTIC MISSILES.
ALL OF THIS WILL BE
MEMORIALIZED.
IF IRAN VIOLATES THE DEAL, ALL
THESE SANCTIONS WILL SNAP BACK
INTO PLACE.
THERE'S A VERY CLEAR INCENTIVE
FOR IRAN TO FOLLOW THROUGH AND